there's a huge incentive for a lot of
companies and governments to keep us
unhealthy there's a huge incentive when
you're unhealthy you're dependent when
you're unhealthy you can be manipulated
very easily when you're unhealthy you
use lots of pharmaceuticals when you're
unhealthy your consumption habits
are different healthy people don't
consume in the same way that unhealthy
people do we don't spend a lot of money
on you know Pharmaceuticals like go to
the grocery store what percentage of the
of the products and Foods in there are
maybe Loosely directed towards unhealthy
habits you know we just went through
this pandemic and if you were unhealthy
it was it was easier for you to be
afraid it's harder to manipulate uh
people when they're fit healthy and
confident like so many products so many
products would go bankrupt if everybody
all of a sudden became healthy